he is a pro Football Hall of Famer Dan
Fouts who's gonna be calling Chargers
Giants and he joins us here on the Rich
Eisen show how are you Dan well real
good rich were ants which we are
anticipating will be a real fun meeting
well I mean we'll you know I want to put
a quick pin in in that and and get your
take on what we're seeing from Tom Brady
is a 40 year old quarterback who is you
know getting beaten up there's no
question about it but it seems to be
performing with the exception of one
airmailed interception was first on the
road in the regular season in two years
he looks the same old Tom Brady to me
Dan what do you think yeah he really
does look good I'm a little concerned
though with how many times he's taking
some big hits in the last couple of
games you know he's been so durable
throughout his career but at forty years
old those hits will start to take a toll
we haven't seen it yet and last night
was a good example of it but you know he
is just remarkable I guess you know
there's so many adjectives you can use
for him but the fact that he is
performing at this high of a level
really on a team that is underperforming
at this point yeah I mean you can call
them an underperforming 3 & 2 team
there's no there's no question about
that but would you consider is Tom when
you when you walk in that bust room and
you look at all the colleagues of yours
Dan in the Pro Football Hall of Fame is
Tom the greatest quarterback of all time
in your opinion well you know you can
have this debate and really what it
comes down to is who's your favorite I
mean that the debate used to be is it
Unitas and then it was Montana and then
now it's Brady the Favre is thrown in
there so he really they're all great and
you know with with tom you've got the
statistics and the rings to back up your
debate so is he the greatest of all time
I think it just depends on who you like
and I like him a lot but I also like the
other guys a lot too so let's get to
your game now the Los Angeles chargers
which again I'm still getting used to
saying against the New York Giants Owen
for and Owen for
how did we get to this point with these
teams on from what you've seen either on
film or with your own set of eyes Dan
well rich they're really mirrors of each
of each other because you know the old
adage is in the NFL and in college
football even you got to run the ball
and then you got to stop the run well
neither of these teams can do either and
I think that's why we're in the position
that we're in right now with them both
being oh and four really you talk about
underperforming the Giants eleven and
five last year with great expectations
for this year and the charges with all
the distraction of having to move the
franchise I think it's taking a toll on
them as well so you think the move is
definitely effect as shown up in those
standings with the Chargers well you
know they're a better team than Owen for
I think first of all the other thing is
is that you know the scheduler really
did them a favor by giving them three
home games in their first four games but
the way that you know their inability to
close out games as it affected the the
fan support and also the knowledge that
opposing team fans can go to Southern
sunny Southern California and you know
go to a football game and buy tickets
from the charger fans so it's really
turned it into you know quite a mess
there in Carson yeah I mean a mess is a
good word for tin I mean do you see in
knowing the organization as well as you
do and the town of San Diego as well as
you do do you think that there is any
possibility of the rumor that that
everyone wants a mulligan on the move
from the NFL to the Chargers to San
Diego of that actually happening I don't
think it'll happen I wouldn't mind if it
did happen because I feel so strongly
about San Diego but you know they're
just financially just too many obstacles
in the way you know it's a with the
flipping tax and then the money that is
owed to the other owners with a
relocation fee so and then you know San
Diego as a government city government is
yet to embrace the fact that they should
you know help an owner build a stadium
there so there's just too many hurdles
at this time although knowing the NFL
they have a way of knocking Turtles down
if it
suits everybody well I can't imagine how
this doesn't suit again I I know that
the Chargers want to make it to that new
stadium but that's so far away and and
then just just hearing the fact that the
Chargers got booed by the crowd last
week when the Eagles were in because the
Eagles fans outnumbered the Chargers
fans I've never heard of something like
that Dan ever well know it's never
happened before and it's embarrassing
it's unfortunate it's frustrating and I
think you start to see the frustration
in the charger players at times you know
it's it's tough to lose obviously I was
once on a team that lost 11 games in a
row back in 1975 and the thing about
football is it when you win a game
you're a winner until you wake up and
sober up on Monday morning if you lose
your loser until you win again so it's
tough as much mentally as it is
physically Pro Football Hall of Famer
Dan Fouts calling the game on CBS
between the charges and the Giants right
here on the Rich Eisen show who's the
best team you've seen so far with you
and I an eagle in the booth that you've
seen this year Dan well that's a good
question because we haven't seen a lot
of great teams yet you know I very
impressed with deshaun Watson against
the Patriots a couple weeks back when he
got his debut and and I think the Texans
have found themselves a quarterback we
did see the Rams they're an interesting
team that to make the turnaround that
they have so far what about Raiders Dan
I know I know you saw the Raiders right
I think you did the Jets Raiders game
which is the last Raiders win so far in
the season what do you make of them in
their in their foray without derrick
karr for the time being here well that's
the thing I mean we don't know what EJ
Manuel can do with that Raider team they
were disappointing in their last game
out when when dark car gets hurt but
they are talented and they're still
learning how to to win to win games with
that team but
they're really going to be tested now
with with car out but that's a positive
thing for that injury is there are ways
of treating that I had the similar
injury in my career and you can play
through that it's all a matter of pain
tolerance and and I know that cars are
tough get a couple more minutes here
with Dan Fouts on the Rich Eisen show
who is the young quarterback you'd most
want to build a franchise around right
now Dan but I think I just mentioned him
do Shawn Watson would be my guy right
now really though you know Carson Wentz
is impressive as well
I like Marcus Mariota because he's a
he's a duck you know and no ducks a
great quarterback guys going back to Van
Brocklin so he was a lot of good ones
there's dak - I don't think people are
considering him as they I guess a young
quarterback because he looked so mature
and performed so well as a rookie what
do you think about dak in his second
season so far from what you've seen from
him Dan yeah I like that Chris got a lot
to he he's cool you know and I think
that's an important attribute for a
young quarterback because there's a lot
of pressure there's a lot of things that
go on and he's been able to handle not
only being a quarterback in the NFL but
being the quarterback of the Dallas
Cowboys you know and just to go full
circle now that we've talked about
quarterbacks and Brady in this
conversation
Brady's high school about a month ago
put out a video of a local sportscaster
in the Bay Area doing a feature on this
kid from San Mateo would you recall who
that local sportscaster was Dan
you know I do and he was really young
looking and sharp he was really and he
also predicted that Tom Brady yes you
did I'm sure back in the day do you do
you recall that gig where you met Tom
back then yeah I do and the premise was
that we were interviewing the tops for
high school prospects going into college
and and I was interested in talking to
Tom because at Sara high school that was
one of our rivals from my high school
and the big thing about Brady was how
come you're not going to Cal or Stanford
or SC
going all the way back to Michigan and
he was cool with his answer and Andy and
also I asked him about his scouting
report what it would say and he said
well I'm accurate I've got a strong arm
but I got to work on my speed yes that
works that works what was his answer as
to why I went to Michigan do you call it
no no it was all legal no no no I was
just saying that cuz it cuz cuz I'm a
smart brilliant guy is that why I went
because he was going to Michigan I just
didn't know that's why I was just
wondering what his response was yeah no
he thought that it would be the best
opportunity for middle and as it turned
out you know he beat up drew Henson
there and it worked out great Dan always
appreciate our chat say hot iron for me
and we'll look forward to your calling
on this fascinating game that some we're
assuming somebody's got to win that'll
be great if it's a job yeah
we don't want to tie nobody near you got
it that stands out the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
if you liked that video be sure to
download our app and I'll be sure to
move week six games to Saturday for that
wedding you have to go to